let's talk about call of duty advanced
warfare there's a huge multiplayer
reveal event last week dan Rikard from
giant bomb was there Rob handlery from
gaze law was there I was my freshman
from giant home on vacation you're on
vacation I saw the game at e3 though so
I'm familiar familiar with the year with
the detail XO jumping yeah business art
well let's talk about it because this is
called Duty multiplayer I think Jeff you
probably more call of duty multiplayer
experience than all of us on the right
here combined dan do you play much yeah
I've kind of been the call of duty guy
for the last like several years well
that's right because you at Game
Informer you said you did the cover
story for it right the referee for
grants warfare and ghosts and I did all
the review and like multiplayer trips
and all that stuff so yeah so you guys
got chops Rob I played a lot of the r
you know the first couple and then kind
of dropped off on ghost plate like only
a couple hours well advanced warfare of
course the big thing is movement is you
got like a double jump you can do this
like dash to the side business and what
I think it's pretty friggin great like I
think it is just this like really neat
kinetic change up to the way those
matches play what do you guys think I
like I would have the the basic stuff
you can do like the dash is the Dodgers
and things like that but you can also go
into your customization and pick that
like extra XO ability whether it's the
midair hover or you know the boost slam
thing where you punch down on the ground
with that finite battery so you know you
basically have to pick and choose when
to use that so are the the soldiers as
resilient as they always have been like
they just go down in a few shots because
that's that's that kind of ground pound
thing seems like you would just get shot
out of the air over and over again I'd
have to be real fast right yeah I've
actually seen the ground I feel like
it's not something you want to do when
you're it's facing off with someone
you're like double jump and try to
ground pounds just gonna be like a
almost like a stealth thing like you got
it behind somebody and you're like check
this out BAM yeah I guess I kind of
someone yes jump down on him and lunch
and because it's so easy to get to
different levels of the map now with the
double jump yeah you know and yeah the
mobility is huge and and it's one of
those things where you know it's like
Call of Duty's been so just stayed and
plane for four years and years that you
know at least they're finally making
basic changes to just mobility and stuff
like that
could be huge so I came away from my
time with it going like this could be
cool as opposed to you know adding up
you know what more dogs I mean they were
kept they kept trying to top themselves
i felt like now they know they
eliminated like death shrieks just basic
scorestreaks now but going back on
dashing the coolest thing was like
remember when the last matches we played
it was kind of finally kind of like
synapses my brain we're hitting it was
like guy on a platform walking above me
how do I get to him jump up and then
left and chalk on the face like it was
just immediate gratification we're like
once that's in the mix you can have some
really interesting gameplay yeah it
seems like you know it's I think there
are some people that are quick to just
go like all looks like titanfall is like
yeah it does but like that the exosuits
are it's not mobile the same way
titanfall is and and like there's
certainly some similarities there but I
think it they're carving out their own
thing it's a different kind of mobility
right with titanfall you need to kind of
you have the double jump right but you
have to in order to make the most of
titanfall you're running a long wall
you're doing all hop small this like
really cool parkour stuff than that I
really love this is you know this is
different this seems like a slightly
more deliberate than that where it is
that kind of just like double jump boost
left like it's almost like UT or
something mm-hmm with the kind of double
tap dashes and that sort of stuff yeah
with those Dukes yeah it feels like
there's more weight to them than there
is in titanfall titanfall is kind of I
don't want to say floaty but I mean you
can really just be sprint around doing
all the wall jump the wall gym stuff and
like this yet deliver it's probably good
word for it so you can dodge something
or get out of the way of a grenade or
something but you're not just flying all
over the map and I think because of that
the short-range boost and it's you know
the hover is you know it's a short-range
hover you're not going to like be
hovering around the map like it's some
kind of drone guy raining down death
upon everybody but it's all sort of
focused on this short term
maneuverability dislike just a quick
move quick sort of engagement and I
think that the way that call of duty's
always been is firefights are very quick
it's all about it's about positioning
and then you know once you guys are
actually shooting at each other it's
almost it's over like almost immediately
after that so having that stuff crammed
into that sort of that speed is you know
I think really interesting that seems
like a difficult thing to you know it's
it'll lead to situations where you go
like well you know I could just pull the
trigger because I know that
works but maybe in some cases a side
dash would be you know a smarter idea
assuming you can then reposition like I
might actually able to astor than they'd
out of the way of someone shooting at me
yes opposed to just oh the first bullet
hit me odd mom dead yeah I said because
the next two are going to hit before I
can react and move significantly if you
can actually dash then sort stretches
out that encounter baby yeah it's kind
of smart the way they map it to the
controller because you know clicking the
left stick is always going to sprint
forward but it doesn't really do
anything if you're going left and right
or back and now I mean it's just
basically click is the extra speed and
whatever direction you're holding the
left stick so that makes a lot of sense
yeah I'm really curious to see like down
the road like like when we were playing
not many people were using that it was
only the last couple of matches were
like oh I finally like pull that off
successfully in the trailer that I just
saw you get comfortable with it yeah and
once that starts happening I really see
that game looking a lot different and
just feeling a lot different like you
know instead of just like headshots it's
going to be like oh that combo move he
just pulled light on that's going to be
something to look forward to and I think
especially in a blink mode which is the
new sort of mode that they were showing
off the event we went to it's uh you
know this is a neutral ball that you
have to throw into this glowing sphere
on either end of the map the fact that
you know those Juke maneuvers that
maneuverability when you're trying to
run the ball from point A to B you know
that opens up a whole different kind of
pace it feels like an American
Gladiators events you kind of look you
get extra points if you like dunk it
through by boosting through yeah yeah I
like that a lot for me though the the
mode conversation just starts and stops
with like did they put headquarters in
it or not because that's you know like
ghosts didn't have it was like why why
would you not do that headquarters this
you james kind of the other mode it's
like there's Team Deathmatch and there's
headquarters and then nations are done
there's there's others so my governess
it's alright oh like its domination is
like older than me at this point this is
just like come on team deathmatches the
mode that's that's the the mode that
lasts and then you know headquarters was
kind of the young upstart that was fun
but oh there's hard point that's coming
on back okay yeah hard part's got to
yeah we we even touched briefly on
uplink how you could mean especially
with me all this customization of class
never like that
but we were almost gained a conversation
about like like a football team like
different actual type of people
customized for different things like you
know running up the ball he would be
decked out with it you know double EXO
abilities just because that's always
doing he's running you know the running
running boosts and then maybe I can help
regenerate like and then you got maybe
like a QB throwing a downfield like
that's all they're doing like you could
basically see a team coming Connie and I
think that some of differentiates itself
from modes like oddball and other sort
of control the ball stuff that we've
seen before it's you can do this pass
and I didn't notice this until we're
going back and looking at the footage
but if you have the ball and you're
running and any of your teammates get
into your view it'll like auto select
one of them as a pass target and then
you just pull the left trigger and gun
it to them yeah do you realistically
think anyone's gonna actually care about
that mode all I want to do it I mean
like like beyond like I want to do it
and then like play it for the first week
like I feel like if you look at you know
call of duty modes and you look at the
player counts we are just talking about
TDM and death and and nomination know
for sure and that's like normally what I
play yeah that's I can see giving as
much traction as like you know gun game
and some of those added like you know
one of the chamber modes the tray arcs
put in the leg there's the one you want
to play when ya don't just want to go
play the brochure yeah yeah exactly yeah
it's not going to get the numbers of TDM
kids or whatever but they all play this
one as hard things where it's like you
know I feel like you know there's
expectation that need to keep coming up
with new things and all sort of stuff
but ultimately people are just going to
play those two modes so is this a new I
mean the movement of Call of Duty you
optimistic about the future do you think
this will be I mean certainly it seems
like we're all welcoming it do you think
that the consuming public buying
millions of call duty copies a year I
think it's real it is it is definitely
risky on their part because if you look
at you know kind of it almost feels like
they've been afraid to make drastic
changes to call of duty because it broke
mr. golden goose yeah you know like if
you if you mess with it too much you
know it's no longer the game that people
fell in love with but I think they've
reached a point now I mean you look at
ghosts you look at kind of just the
player numbers and stuff like that it
didn't seem like it had the staying
power like they obviously need to make
changes yeah and and personally as
someone who's just been you know getting
like more and more bored with it as the
years go on like this is the most
dramatic change they've yeah you know
it's not just like hey we came up with a
nine
any way to unlock stuff though they came
up with that too they definitely yeah
there's a pic 13 now Jan oh it's a whole
different game part that's whoa and then
loot crates right cuz battlefield but
yeah everyone's favorite like that
outfield mass effects and men muttering
that you're doing microtransactions in
there so you think they will that's
always been the thing they like Call of
Duty made so much money that they always
were like we don't need to sell currency
or are you know we don't charge for
multiplayer they tried without leave I
mean yeah that yeah they did it leave
right and then you know obviously they
sold this Snoop Dogg voice pack which is
fantastic i use it whenever i'm playing
call of duty ghosts i use this new dog
with you hmm ill it and yeah so it's
like one of the things we're like you
look at the loot crate so you look at it
like oh how it was a mass effect 3 and
you're like oh I'm sorry like start
buying crates right watch over there and
they get something neat who knows you
may be paying for little things and call
of duty allegan to the big but these are
questions and also the crap for a long
time like you know over the last couple
of years they've you know they've been
getting into selling you garbage so why
not new innovative ways yeah so you go
that's right this weapons skin that
you'll barely see on your gun because
you're who looks at that cuz you're
sprinting it looks like weed leaves all
right Lee all right all right call of
duty advanced warfare that sound like a
few months so you know a lot about it
probably see a little bit more before
shutdown
you